ohio police
kill black teenage girls seen
threatening others with knife this is
reuters story police in columbus ohio
on tuesday fatally shot a black teenage
girl they confronted as she
uh lunged at two people with a knife as
seen in a police video footage of the
count authority said authorities
described the teenager
who was fatally shot at 15 years old
that's 15 years old but family members
have identified her
mckee bryan age 16 the police officer
who opened fire
was not identified but appears from the
video to be white the interim columbus
police chief michael wood said the
officer would be taken off the street
pending an investigation releasing
police body camera video of tuesday's
shooting hours later would set officers
involved
were responding to a 9-1-1 emergency
call from someone who reported an
attempted stabbing at a home
on the city's south side uh uh
southeast side if you have the video to
just show this go ahead kai just to
count if you can flip the camera so we
can stop it
if you can flip the screen for the
screen to be bigger than us and when
we're ready go right ahead
go ahead buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
stop to stop the video okay uh
that was she wasn't threatening she was
getting ready to stab that girl
that was not a threat can you go back to
to exactly right before
is there uh there's pictures of it okay
go back and pull up the pictures to see
if there's pictures of this pictures of
it
and that that that teenage girl farther
far further than a threat that's for
damn sure
go to images
okay so that's the second one go to the
second one
click on it again that's cbs news
there's a knife right there what a
position to be in as a cop
that happening right in front of you
so say that again
especially as you're pulling up like
you're just getting for it to escalate
that quickly and how old is a cop 20 uh
20 some years old
how old was the cop a younger child okay
so what do you think when you see this
what's the first thing you think about
when you see this
he saved a young black girl's life
that's what he did she was that that's a
look how big that girl is that she could
she's going to stab with force and the
other girl's skinny
she's going to stab her with force
that's not slashing she's going
straight for a direct hit and look how
big that knife is pat
what is that six seven inches maybe we
can't see it we don't want to speculate
but it's a good six inches look at it
look at her grip on it it's a six
probably five or six inch that's gonna
kill this girl
i mean that's that's the cop did what he
was supposed to do
yeah i don't know i just want to go back
to my initial point de-escalate the
police he just ran up
he saw something going down how many how
many shots did he fire
if we could i i saw i heard at least
three or four shots
if you saw if bro if we're looking at
this through a camera we can see the
knife imagine what he can see live
he's watching that knife it's so obvious
i think i don't think anything is
obvious at this point because i think
the facts need to play out
clearly she has a knife you need more
effects than that that's crazy what if
it was yours
is that a butter knife is that a is that
is that a machete i don't know what that
is
okay i'll put you this way what if that
was your daughter on the other side of
the night would you want to care
to see if it was a butter knife it was a
fake knife would you want it would you
care
here's the question if it was my
daughter's i'm not hurt i'm not i'm not
picking sides here i have questions i
don't have answers i don't have
solutions here i've got a lot of
freaking questions
why does the cop need to roll up and
just bang bang bang take someone's life
that's exactly what he did what are you
doing the cop rolled up the girl fell
go back to the video at the beginning go
back to the video at the beginning this
is just a question
back like original when he comes in go
all the way to the beginning just press
play from the beginning he's not running
out of his card
i'm gonna slow it down yeah puts a speed
put point five
yeah there you go
okay he comes out he has no idea
everything looks peaceful so far
the girl is standing there in the pink
okay
[Applause]
somebody falls down
then he draws his gun oh oh
i got it so got it so that's a cop right
there by the way
yeah already in the middle who has not
drawn his gun
okay so that cop's going to have a
perspective yeah but but here's the
here's the uh in that situation you have
one of two choices
if you don't shoot somebody who's about
to kill another
stab another person right in front of
you then
you allowed somebody to be stabbed it is
a very technical situation here
on what to do you might know the answer
to this what's that
why can't you shoot her in the leg or in
the arm or in the ass
that's why do you need to take someone
hold on hold on they actually did a
study and it's funny that you say that
because i was watching this study
yesterday
last night in my hotel cops are not me
they're not taught to shoot and
here's the logical side behind it he
says we don't teach to shoot the leg or
the arm
because it's such a small target that's
moving
if that cop misses that bullet goes past
the
plaster person and it can kill somebody
else that has nothing to do with the
innocent
so this is we teach them to shoot to the
biggest body mass
because the per person typically is
getting shot
is in the action of committing a crime
if we go for the leg or the arm
okay and i'm moving to jesus and that
that was interesting with the cops
people can't even hit targets that are
still at a gun range
let alone somebody that's moving around
you shoot towards the leg
that that bullet ricochets and it hits
an innocent person
now you're looking at shooting somebody
that's innocent they have to go to the
biggest body mass
to make sure that those bullets do not
go past anybody
go to the tweet go to the tweet of what
um
newsom what newsome not not governor
newsom there's a tweet
uh uh that uh let me see if this yeah so
uh uh bree newsom said teenagers have
been having a dream
by the way huh who's bree newsome bree
newsome uh she's an advocate for bill
don't click on it because if you do
you're gonna lose a tweet
teenagers have been having fights
including fights involving knives for
eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of the
teenagers you all need help
i mean that's sincerely unbelievable go
click on it she has 200 retweets
isn't it not even that she's got more
than 1200 retweets this is a person
that's got 467 000
followers artists grassroots organizer
for free black women scale 30 feet
flagpole
a remove south carolina uh confederate
flag in protest in june 27 2015 so she's
uh
proud of that so that's uh
that's kind of the place where we are
right now so cops now don't get involved
in
knife fights okay what are you supposed
to do this one the reasons why i called
bernard carrick this morning him and i
were having a conversation this morning
bernard carrick was a former
head of the nypd for years he was the
guy that helped clean new york with
mayor giuliani back in the days when new
york had the whole
situation going on he was the guy was
not easy being bernard you have to be
just as strong of a personality to go up
against the mob and go up against
everybody else and
carrick was pretty much that scary of a
guy in the streets where if he came out
people knew something was going on
and he sees this he says what are you
doing in a situation like that so
let's talk solutions let's talk
solutions somebody here commented
something very interesting
somebody commented here let me read it
to you uh and
gave 20 bucks let me see if i can find
this guy ah man i wish i would i thought
i
took a screenshot somebody said okay
here we go
all of the suited and booted 20 bucks
all of this attention on police has an
end game of robocop coming in and
policing the public
this would protect the assets of the
rich much more protection without human
emotion also much more submission
think about that right there okay so
every time a cop comes
lebron sends a tweet and lebron says
what he puts up a tweet that he takes
down
momentarily because the backlash he got
he puts to saying you're next
okay and obviously time clock
accountability he takes it down
then he has his next tweet if you want
to read out his next tweet i don't know
if you have it or not if you don't have
it
uh maybe he removed it or not but he has
a couple of
he got so much heat for this yesterday
and he says i'm so damn tired uh i've
seen black people killed by police i
took the tweet down because it's being
used to create more hate this isn't
about one officer it's about the entire
system and they always use
our words to create more racism i'm so
desperate for more
accountability right what an idiot yeah
so so that's lebron james on what you
got so
how do you solve this how do you solve
this you know
how do you how do you prevent emotions
from taking place what do you do like
you see that one movie where everything
is
you know perpetuating like right before
crime is about to happen
minority minority report where they
catch you you know
is the solution having billions of
cameras on the streets which we already
have but i'm talking like the government
having billions of cameras on the street
is the solution more surveillance so
what are you really asking for
right the same person that said you know
black teenage
black kids have been using knives for
the long eons you know leave them alone
let them handle in the streets
themselves
if you go back and read what she says
she's for
getting rid of cops and letting
communities take take care of themselves
without cops being involved
is that really the right solution is
technology the solution
is is more control the solution is more
cameras the solution
we were reading a book this month called
the speed of trust
and i had my executives reading this
book and in the book it talked about
what tsa did
when tsa came out in 2001 november of
2001 right after 9 11 happened under
president bush administration they came
up with tsa
they said what ended up happening is it
used to take 30 minutes for you to get
on your flight when it would go to the
airport now it's 90 minutes
because we don't trust more it's now 90
minutes to go on a flight then it used
to be 30 minutes
of what people used to do so they took
60 minutes away from people that are
busy trying to be productive trying to
work
trying to get to their places simply
because we don't trust so if we go in
the direction of trying to find a
solution for this
it's gonna have to come up at a price of
giving up something
is that giving up your freedom of being
monitored and watched non-stop is it
more camera is it
you know robocop type of deal is it are
we going and having
you know uh these these uh
what do you call it robot type of you
know the whole robocop things being
placed everywhere that scene what's
happening
what becomes a solution for something
like this i don't know what the solution
is but something that just kind of
crossed my mind i don't think we need
more cameras more surveillance i don't
think we need more big brother i don't
think we need a george orwellian 1984
type situation that's not what i think
but
getting back to lebron thing and the
accountability i wonder i wonder
and this is something i probably never
even said out loud and i just kind of
thought about it but
imagine if that girl would have actually
stabbed
the other girl um black on black that
would have been a black on like if she
would have died that would have been a
black-on-black crime right
would love would have lebron said
anything no would
uh anyone have said anything no would
i mean black people get killed by other
black people in chicago
all the time and i get that that's a
major concern people do talk about it
anyone who says well they don't talk
about it they're probably wrong because
people do talk about it a lot who talks
about it
it's a it's a thing that people talk who
talks about the specific everyone knows
everyone no absolutely not so nobody
talks about it not not not cnn
not msnbc everyone has talked about
chicken okay let me ask everyone let me
ask you
let me ask you a question for every one
minute that they've spent
talking about that black on black crime
how much have they spent talking about
white on black crime okay cool that
that's where i was going with this so i
wasn't even talking about what's the
race talking about police on
what's the ratio 101 20 to 140 to one
because
yes yes okay yes yes remember one of the
seven reasons for fallen of an empire is
to create a division amongst the country
and that's the media i can go on the
media rail about the media and the
division that they're causing
for the rest of the show but ultimately
my point is this
those were two black people fighting
yeah they could have been two white
people it could have been two hispanics
could have been two jews whatever but
that's the facts of this case
those were two black people fighting
okay if the black one bigger black girl
killed the skinnier of the black girl
where would have been the outrage what
would have been the there wouldn't have
been anything you wouldn't even heard
about it that's my point
that's ultimately my point that's why i
said i'm probably saying something that
people have been like whoa what the
[__] he talking about
so that's point number six the
the the reality is what's worse
what's worse a civilian killing another
civilian black on black crime in this
particular instance
or a cop rolling up quote-unquote doing
his job
and killing the person the perpetrator
in this case who has a weapon in her
hand
and he already says back up back up back
up so one way or another someone was
gonna die
what's worse the the one girl killing
another girl
or the cop killing socially i'm just
saying that that's the reality
there's different angles socially or
justice or or justice wise
i'm posing the question but the reality
is no
no that's not is it justice or is it or
is it socially
is it justice or is it social is it just
if you're talking about justice
what's worse or is it socially what's
worse because we're obviously seeing
what socially is the worst
thing they're calling him a racist and
that now i don't i don't think he's a
look i don't think he's a racist he just
rolled up and he saw some i don't know
this person we don't
nobody knows him the facts will kind of
play out i think he was
put in a difficult situation like i
talked about initially
cops who are 25 years old like i look
pretty young you might be 30 i don't
know
they're asked to be to de-escalate
situations they're asked to be
negotiators they're asked to be
paramedics and emts and they're asked to
do so much
and in the middle of all that and you
gave a great explanation of why he had
to shoot for the body and kill somebody
um they're asked to do so much so
the i don't you can't just say oh he's
racist
he's white he killed her he's racist no
she had a knife in her hand bro
so i'm just posing the question like
someone was gonna mo
likely die like if if if he would have
stabbed
if she would have stabbed the other girl
it would have just been another we need
to it would have been another story in
the newspaper no big deal
because the cop did it no one would it's
the front page so so okay
so this is now leading me to one area of
the freedom that we have in america
that's become a problematic lately by
the way somebody said a couple things
here
i want to read a couple of the comments
one of them um
you can read it on your own by bobby
collins he's not happy what you said he
says i love you
but you're uh uh how can you question
this clear video but the george floyd
was a clear day
uh clear as day bobby collins is calling
you out and calling him
calling calling video what happened with
george floyd and another person said
no no hold on hold on the video that was
shown by the media or the actual videos
by the journalists read this comment
right here uh and adam is a pizza
i love you but you're how can you
question this clear
a third say they disagree with the
verdict two thirds
agree with the vote okay from this
audience two thirds hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on you can
you can you can and and this is and this
is the reality behind things
just because a lot of the mass agreed
doesn't mean it's right okay so
maybe here here remember this the
majority of people
are why do you want to
listen to me most people wake up in the
morning
they make their coffee they make their
breakfast they do they send they go to
work they send their kids to school they
come back and they have after-school
activities
the majority is most people both on the
right and the left
are not sitting there doing their
homework on this all they watched was
was shown to them on the media
that's the reality behind things so you
can still be
you can you can say you can be on one
side of the political spectrum
and still believe the narrative that was
pushed i'm not defending
i'm talking about in general you can
believe the narrative that was pushed
because right now there's a narrative
being pushed by lebron james
and this other lady whatever her name
was that that was a little
innocent girl that is mostly a
peacemaker like her mom said stabbing
another girl
and if you don't look into it you'll
believe that so i don't care if the
masses believe something
the reality is there is another video
with another angle
with the man having his knee on his back
that is reality that you don't like it
because here mark twain said it's easier
to fool people than to make them
it is easier to fool people that to
convince them they have been fooled
okay that's what mark twain says is the
fact that you can still be on one side
of the political spectrum
and and believe what was pushed on you
on both sides because you don't know the
truth
so the truth is you don't know the truth
so to think that something's
clear as day no [__] no it's not
clear because
you don't know the other side because
you haven't done your homework on it so
now on this side what the what the
gentleman was trying to tell you was
on one side you're like yeah yeah yeah
he killed him you see a knife and
somebody's being stabbed and you're like
well i don't know why did you just get
off and bang bang
like that doesn't i understand where
he's coming from like
i don't know what this guy's point was
his point is that on one is clear as day
this was not clear as day my point is
that what's your point
and when you're clear and you're set
stone that it was i didn't say anything
you see a girl right here almost getting
stabbed and you're not clear about it
bro i just said i don't like this
video she has a knife in her hand that's
all we know oh that's all so it's not
going in a certain direction it's not
aiming at somebody right
yes okay aimed at the other girl i just
i just basically said someone was gonna
get murdered
no no you didn't ricky stop it
stop it bro i don't know your point let
me let me read this other one somebody
said why don't you just tase them
instead of shooting them jimmy kalut
said why don't you taste her instead of
shooting her because it goes backpack
yeah
right but you have a little girl what if
what if
she was on the other side of the knife
would you want to taser her no there's
no question about it
it's easy to take absolutely i'm just
reading the comment a person said
drew mega just said as a son of two
jamaican parents i think the cop was
justifiable
he saved her by milliseconds he's more
of a hero than a villain
he's not a villain at all yeah mark
marine mark marine mark the mariner
uh cop shoots girl attacking dies
girl saved cop doesn't shoot girl dies
attacker dies other people possibly
injured or killed
cop possibly dies or is injured by a
deadly weapon
you know you know who the most important
perspective on this entire thing is
what's that who's the most important
perspective that we want to hear of out
of this entire situation
no who the girl that's about to get
stabbed
i'd love to hear what she has that would
not be a bad idea actually i would love
to hear what she has to say see if i can
get a hold of her
okay see falling that's the person we
need to hear from if she says
no i was about to get killed the cops
saved my life that's an interesting
perspective
but if by chance yeah she says no the
cop came in he didn't have to kill her
she was my friend we had a little fight
that's a totally different person damn
that's crazy i've had a little fight
with my friends not gonna try to stop me
that's crazy okay well i mean good
congratulations on having friends
i don't know what happened there the
point is the one perspective we do need
to hear from is the girl who's
you need a person you need a perspective
after watching the video it's funny you
don't need a perspective with javane but
now you need a perspective here i don't
know why you're so focused on defending
shout outs i'm not
because spending your time because
you're basically saying well his knee
was on his back so it's okay
well his name is still on his goddamn
back that's a huge difference for his
knee on his neck
now when you're not when you're pinned
on the ground and against a against the
curb
you're acting like well his knee was on
his back so no big deal ricky that
doesn't do it
ricky did say if you got a guy in
handcuffs why are you putting the knee
on the glass okay
he already said that uh you're basically
saying because okay you did say that but
you're also saying
his knee was on his back it's not a big
deal you're super adamant about it
all i'm saying is you're super adamant
about one but you're not adamant about
the other why do you need a perspective
i if somebody's getting stabbed i don't
need a perspective i'm going to shoot
the person that's possibly going to be
harming the other person there's no
perspective to look at the girl has a
knife and she's in full
she helps back she's in full swing to
stop this girl there is no perspective
bro that's that's that's all there is to
it so she should have died off
well you're gonna kill somebody else and
that was my point if someone was no that
was not your point
i did say that it's a black on black
crime point yes that's okay
you're gonna be all right yeah i need
700 more dollars in quarters immediately
all right so this this
uh this is uh i get taxed on it so you
will too
this is a this is a very interesting
thing because the the part that's a bit
confusing is the following adam
when sometimes you hear when somebody
uses
uh a gun to protect somebody that guy
is a you know the cop is doing he's the
criminal right what he's doing but if on
the other side
if you hear on the uh uh somebody that
kills
uh a black that kills others sometimes
you hear all its mental issues you know
he had mental problems he had gun it's
the gun's fault that's
accountability is very contradictory
right it's very contradictory it's only
what story can be used to
validate your story to spin to divide
even more and
and the part where i was going with this
was the following here's where i was
going with this
before you know you guys had your
discourse you know
the freedoms that america gives are what
freedom of speech freedom of assembly
freedom of uh enterprise you know
freedom of all this stuff second
religion
religion that's right it's your top one
so freedom of religion all these things
that it does right
there there is an issue with press for
me
there isn't an issue with press for me
you have an issue with free traffic
there's an issue with press like oh yeah
yeah let me give you an idea what i mean
by there's an issue with press
who who is the press accountable to
nobody and i know it's the people
obviously it's the people that hold the
press accountable right
you can't say this you can't say that
you can't say this but
let me tell you man right now the the
press doesn't have a lot of pushback the
press doesn't have a lot of
accountability the press doesn't have a
lot of uh
you know in the nba you say something
about the referee get fined
in the envy you say something about the
referee the league finds you
right in the media you get to say
anything there are no fines
very rarely do you hear this person was
suspended for one day you know like even
what what happened with uh back in the
days with the comedian
chappelle when they're like well you're
going a little bit too much you know i
think we gotta shut him down right he's
like i'm just done i'm gonna take a
break and then he comes back
hitting hard again right where is the
press being held accountable for this
where's the press being held accountable
for pushing a story for three years that
was a lie and then they say ah
it's not a big okay let's talk about
what's going on today and they just move
on where's the level of accountability
for the press
these are the guys that we these are
journalists they went to school to be
journalists right i mean they go to
school to be a journalist these guys get
paid
to get on camera and report to us what's
going on this is what they get paid to
do
and they take a story like this and they
just spin it to the way they want it and
then boom
america divides it's a v if if i were
if you were to tell me what is your
biggest concern long term
what's your biggest concern long term
you know that bree newsome that said
well you know all this stuff racism you
know
we'll be using knives against each other
for eons just kind of leave us alone
or aoc that goes out there this is just
a injustice that's taking place
and lebron hey who's next your next this
is a person like lebron with the kind of
influence you got to put the guy's
picture
and you say you're next you put the guys
by the way by the way that that's
somebody's
life but he's not gonna get suspended
twitter's not gonna go do anything to
him and that's okay
why so the level of accountability is
not
he potentially put this man you realize
that somebody's
that's somebody's kid as well that we're
talking about
you put his picture on blast saying
you're next
not saying anything like you know
hey uh it's unfair what happened today
you know the
you're next in the world of what you're
next means to
a lot of people yeah your next has a lot
of interpretations and by the way
yep to the wrong person who's a die hard
lebron fan
and says you know what yeah yeah you're
next let me find this mother you know
yep
you got to be careful so i think same
thing with a die-hard trump fan when
they
do all that well no but he was held
accountable though that's true so but
he's not held accountable we'll see
what we will see we'll see what do you
mean
tweets already happened okay i don't
think anything will happen but we'll see
what happens if lebron nobody nothing is
going to happen
you're likely but back to your initial
point yeah so you went from press to
lebron
i think just how like when trump tweets
something and you know the fact check
and everything happened with that i
think there does need to be a clear
distinction
these days between fact-based journalism
and opinion-based journalism so i think
if we're gonna go there
i think when hannity does a show or when
don lemon does a show
it should say opinions of this person or
opinion
journalism or when wolf blitzer does a
show
or when neil cavuto does a show these
will say crosstalk
factor okay i mean tucker is opinion
yeah
but there's certain journalists who are
fact-based and they're certain
journalists are opinion based
and there was no clear distinction for a
long time and i think at this point
at this point like if you do the fox
news hour between
lauren ingram tucker carlson um
juan hannity these are all opinions even
the
the the five these are all opinions yeah
same thing for cnn you got cuomo you've
got um
brooke baldwin and you've got these are
all opinions these are not fact-based
journalists i don't know
in the wall street journal though usa
today you do have to attract questions
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question
you think if we went on a
five-year diet of showing stuff on the
news
recognizing unifiers recognizing voice
of reason
recognizing people that are willing to
sit with opposing side and have a debate
a discourse
debate or discourse do you think people
would be inspired to want to be that
more versus if we turned
a divider like lebron into a hero
if we turn dividers into heroes
everybody looks at the playbook and says
i want to also be a divider yep because
that's who we're turning into a hero
kids are growing up saying i want to be
a divider because that's what pays i
want to be divided because that's what's
celebrity
i want to be a divider i think i think
we you disagree with that i don't think
anybody says
i want to be a divider i think they say
i want to stand up for what i believe
and based on those beliefs the
difference between standards you're
going to pick a side
listen nobody says i want to divide
people listen i'm a christian
i'm a christian i consider myself a
christian okay
but you have no idea how skeptical
skeptical of a christian i am
you have no idea so i don't sit there if
you ask any of the christian mentors in
my life what is it like when you talk to
pat
they'll tell you this guy's like what
about this and what about this and what
about this
i don't sit here and say no matter what
dude reason little bit of reasonable
person but what i'm saying is we need to
recognize that element in the world
to get more kids to also want to reason
that is what we're not recognizing
enough of
recognizing the hero that's sitting
there saying i don't
know versus that's not fair jump into
conclusion emotion
turn him into a hero i want to be like
him so i think it's a great idea how do
you implement that how do you implement
no it's not going to happen it's not
going to happen it's not about how you
implement it it doesn't sell
yeah it's not going to happen because it
doesn't
match the narrative there's no way
that'll happen because it doesn't match
the narrative
it's it's no way in the world it's
something that's going to sit there and
say well no no
we can't do that because we're not
pushing our agenda more we're not
pushing our agenda more
pushing our gender more i'm going to
make my prediction to hear today
you know what else happens every time
there's a possibility of an empire
fallen you know what else happens every
time there's a possibility of empire
falling
guess what happens every single time
history repeats itself and crap like
this happens guess what happens a whole
new wave of leaders are born
every time every time
a guy who's tatted up who has the
background that he has
gets inspired pre-he and i meeting you
were never into any capitalism politics
anything
ricky was a guy to himself and now
ricky's out there voice being for the
latino community why because he's
sitting there saying
i can reason with this you're going to
see the kind of leaders that are going
to be raised up the next 10 20 years
like we've never seen before like we've
never seen before
but the direction we're going right now
america's naive if they don't see how
we're being divided right now
pure pathetic what they're doing to us
right now pinning people against each
other you cannot fall for it
unfortunately america is falling forward
and when you say they are you talking
about the media who else specifically
who else would it be outside of the
medium politicians who else would it be
medium politicians people with voices
and perspectives
not that braun's not media lebron's not
apologize absolutely media yeah
lebron is me so anybody's immediately
lebron was a media company he raised 100
million dollars greenhouse what do you
mean he's not media so okay
is anthony davis media like if we're
gonna go there who's anthony who's
anthony david that's a role model
okay so that's a wrong just because
lebron had so was lebron media before he
had a media company lebron's probably
been media for the last five years
because he's been a guy that's uh
uh so if you have a big voice your media
yeah that's
influence in just so you can be on
social media and you can be media right
is that what you're saying
you could be media but you gotta you
gotta use your platform to bring
people to the center to have a discourse
like
you know people say pat the day you fire
adam is the day i watch
the podcast yeah you're you're an idiot
for saying something like that
what do you mean the day i fire at them
i'm going to be on the podcast you know
i cannot believe you gave a socialist a
platform and you brought dan price on
i'm gonna bring him on again
i can't believe you brought richard wolf
socialist professor
who believes in socialism and wants to
make america socialist why would you
bring him on your show
i'll bring him 50 more times i'll bring
you 50 more
why would you have a conversation with a
communist libya slavojiijek
because that's how we are able to reason
and see leaks in the argument and then
you get to make a decision for yourself
but that's not what it is today today
it's let me just bring
everybody that's on my side to validate
my point so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye